So far we've described the address translation process like this.
The offset from the virtual address, simply gets copied to
the physical address. And in order to translate the virtual
page number, we do a look up in the page table,
which is in memory, to find the physical page frame.
Now you may be asking yourself, won't going to memory, for
the page table every time we access a memory address
be slow? In fact, we'll have to go multiple times for
our hierarchical page table. Well indeed it would
be. Thankfully the page tables themselves may end up
in our cache, which can help considerably. But
architects have also created a special purpose cache for
storing page table entries, called the table lookaside
buffer. Or TLB for short. Instead of going through
these slower traditional memory mechanisms, we're taking a special
shortcut. Whereas the caches we talked about earlier are
usually indexed by physical address, the TLB is indexed
by virtual address. After all, its job is to
translate virtual page numbers to physical ones. This is
extra tricky, because one virtual page number may be mapped
to a physical address in one process, but it
might be invalid in another or mapped to different
location. There are two ways to handle this problem.
Some systems simply flush the TLB, on every context switch.
That is, every time the address space switches. This is
a main reason that context switches are considered so costly. Alternatively,
the TLB can use an address space identifier field in the
table, to make sure that the translation in the table is
meant for use in the current context. I should point out,
too, that the kernel sometimes get's special treatment in the TLB.
Because the kernel addresses our constant across processes, there is no
need to flush them from the TLB on a context switch.
Sometimes, too, part of the TLB is reserved for kernel addresses.